turning now to the situation in Haiti
where the United Nations says more than
7 million people a third of the
population are facing food insecurity on
top of that a shortage of clean water
has also led to a cholera outbreak both
food and water are running low because
there's no fuel for delivery trucks due
to a poured blockade by powerful gangs
calls for foreign intervention to ease
the crisis are only adding to the
tensions police fire tear gas at
protesters near the U.S embassy and the
capital Port-au-Prince some waved
Russian Flags they reject foreign
interference and say they fear for their
country's sovereignty
now despite popular opposition Haiti's
government has appealed for
international troops to quell the chaos
and restore order at an emergency
meeting of the U.N security Council
Haiti's foreign minister brought what he
called A Cry of distress from his people
last situation the situation has
dangerously deteriorated
terrible events are taking place every
day
the filth human lives are being lost
their kidnappings public and private
property being destroyed they're rapes
theft looting threats and intimidation
and this plunges the country further
into chaos with extremely serious
consequences for everyone
the United States and Mexico now say
they are preparing a U.N resolution to
authorize an international Mission U.N
Secretary General Antonio guterres
backed the call for her intervention
saying Haitians faced a dramatic
emergency
it's an absolutely
nightmarish situation for the population
anxiety especially Porto Brands we need
an armed action to release the port and
to allow for humanitarian Corridor to be
established
I'm talking of something to be done in
support of the Asian police and I'm
talking of something to be done based on
strict humanitarian criteria
the Security Council is split on the
matter and a vote on the resolution has
not yet been scheduled but there is
still plenty to talk about and for that
I want to bring in Pascal Robert he is a
haitian-american writer and co-host of
the podcast this is Revolution he joins
us from Miami Florida Welcome Mr Robert
this is a fairly unusual move by the
Haitian government how did we get here
well thank you very much for having me
on the first thing we have to understand
is amazing the major reason we're here
is as a consequence of the assassination
of the former elected Hessian President
Joe namuice who was assassinated on July
7th 2021 and afterwards the United
States put in an unelected government
that was not chosen by the Haitian
people which is the current
administration of onion only and much of
the actual unrest that exists in the
country stems from the fact from a large
segment of the population not
recognizing him his authority as a
governor of the Affairs of the people
because they see him as completely as
being told Pawn of the state department
and being unable to dictate the Affairs
of the country and his constant and
current request to have U.S Infamous
intervention as he's done just now
indicates that their instincts are
correct so in terms of the actual
problem we have in the country is that
we have pretty much a government that is
illegitimate India has a large segments
of the population that is governing a
country that has not had an election in
six years years trying to determine the
Affairs by assembling the people that
put him in power in the first place at
in in Haiti has led to the rise of these
gangs how powerful are they
the question is to ask about the gangs
is not so much how powerful are they but
who's financing them explain to me how a
bunch of so-called poor individuals who
are living in Port-au-Prince are getting
weapons shipped to them by for from
Florida all the way into the capitol
who's financing them who has the money
to do such a thing and the question then
becomes is are there people within the
Haitian oligarchy or the Haitian private
sector or maybe former members of the
Haitian government official them who
have interest in trying to destabilize
the country to the point where they
cannot be elections held so that there's
a no real actual Democratic
representation of the voice of the
people and the only consequence is that
the United States and the core group
another foreign foreign International uh
actors who have had a parasitic
relationship with the country going back
to its Inception can come in and find a
way to basically basically undermine the
sovereignty of the Haitian people even
further that's why I kind of resent the
notion that people make this statement
that Haiti is a failed State Haiti is on
a failed state it is a state that has
been failed by the International
Community
what would the International Community
have to do in your opinion to
assist the people that are going through
through economic hardship that are now
suffering uh the conditions that you
know were created by by a tumultuous
history
I think that the first thing that has to
be done is we have to realize that we
have an illegitimate Haitian government
that's sitting in the seat of power in
the country and that they should remove
it there should be a provisional
government made up from the for the
various political parties and civil
society that can come together and
govern with a strict mandate to hold an
election within a year's time and
maintain Security on in the country and
to do that there has to be sure there
has to be the capacity of maintaining
some type of military supervision by a
Haitian police authorities over the gang
territories so that best I would submit
that the International Community could
help us by secondarily buttressing the
international police the internal police
force in Haiti by providing them weapons
and arms training to have underman the
game at best that is that that is the
most tangential relationship I would
agree to having with the International
Community of Haiti when one considers
their long history of undermining the
sovereignty of the country so the UN had
peacekeepers in Haiti for more than a
decade the mission was you know marred
by scandals ranging from Blue helmets
causing a cholera outbreak a gang raping
a teenager it's quite understandable
that people are on the fence about
International intervention is there any
kind of outside assistance that Haitians
would accept
I mean the thing is though the question
that becomes if when people say things
like that the question you ask is that
what is a track record of the
International Community once they have
come and put their boots on the ground
in Haiti and when you if you look quite
carefully you'll see that what they have
done is abuse misused mistreat and even
infectations with cholera at one point
with the last U.N occupation that
existed uh uh a few years or less than a
decade less than 12 15 years ago the
last five years ago excuse me so the
question that becomes is are Haitians
someone irrational when you say well
okay well if you tell us that we can't
govern ourselves what exactly is the
track record that you have when you're
coming on land in our Shores and trying
to govern our Affairs and supposedly for
us in terms of what you do to our people
all right but there is an acute crisis
right now what can be done to help those
in need I think what can be done is that
one of the steps that are necessary are
to one
make sure that we have a legitimate
Haitian government and realize that a
provisional Council government removing
ion we should be the first step he
should go he's because he's not
recognized by the people and he's not
going to be able to do anything that's
going to be able to bring order to the
gov to the country so provisional
Collective government with varying
political parties coming together with
these particular intention of sponsoring
an election within a five year within
one year of its mandate which should be
implemented number two a security Force
budgeting the support of the H of of
international forces giving Haitian
police authorities the Weaponry
necessary to investigate these gangs
with the secondary support of
international officers if necessary
should be put into Power without giving
them the overall say in terms of how
they're they're on board we're gonna
have to leave a therapist called thank
you so much for your time tonight